[Music]
okay take the test it only takes 10
minutes
you regularly make new friends um i
would say like naturally yeah i make
friends pretty easy
um you spend a lot of your free time
exploring various random topics that
pique your interest for sure that's like
what i do in this youtube channel seeing
other people cry can easily make you
feel like you want to cry too
no it's kind of awkward when other
people cry
you often make a backup plan for a
backup plan um i barely have a
first plan so
like i am not a planner um you stay calm
even under a lot of pressure
um i would say yeah
like i'm not really a warrior but
sometimes in volleyball
like i served out the other day when i
was like really close that made me
so i'm mad
to do a little bit of great at social
events
you rarely introduce yourself and talk
to new people and mostly talk to the
ones you already know
um
[Music]
i would say
i rarely i would say disagree i'm pretty
extroverted
um you prefer to completely finish one
project before starting another no it's
a problem like i start way too many
projects you're very sentimental yes
you like
organizing school tools like schedules
and lists i do but i would say i'm
pretty disorganized as a person
so i feel like this is like misleading
because i use those tools because i'm
disorganized but i guess i'll put it for
the little bit
um even a small mistake can cause you to
doubt your overall abilities and
knowledge
not really
you feel comfortable just walking up to
someone you find interesting and
striking up conversation
i feel like
recently i've been so much more
introverted but like
normally in my life yeah um you are not
too interested in discussing various
interpretations and analysis of creative
work what does that mean
um
like i discuss on my youtube channel
different interpretations of stuff and
that's like creative works but i
wouldn't talk about like art
uh i'm gonna just put in the middle
cause i don't really know what that's
asking
um you are more inclined to follow your
head than your heart
uh
i'm really logical but at the end of the
day i'm still a girl like i'm still a
woman
so
like i'm still pretty emotional
but i'd say like fur girl i'm pretty
logical so
i'm gonna do like slightly agree
[Music]
um you prefer just doing what you feel
like at any given moment yeah that's why
i'm up at three freaking 10 in the
morning
oh my god i'm so bad at routines like
terrible
so i'm gonna put it
you
rarely worry about whether you make a
good first impression on people you meet
um
i would say disagree
you enjoy participating in group
activities
uh yes i love group activities
you like books and movies that
you can come up with your own
interpretation of the ending no that'd
be stupid
um
your happiness comes more from helping
others accomplish
things in your own accomplishments
i'm trying to think i really do enjoy
like helping people like i really enjoy
like talking to people about something
that they're passionate about but
i like i'm thinking about volleyball i
feel like if that was true i would have
coached like if i really was passionate
about helping people i would have
coached but it just sounded so boring to
me
um so we're gonna do
i want to go in the middle because i
really do enjoy helping people but more
than my own i don't know
i'm gonna i'm gonna go a little bit to
disagree okay you were interested in so
many things that you find difficult to
choose what to try next agree you're
prone to worrying about things that take
a turn for the worse disagree
you avoid leadership roles in group
settings
oh my gosh
i realized that this is this is where i
really like to be i like to be second in
command i love i hate
having to make the decision and like
leading the group but i love helping a
strong leader
so
like
that that is like the role that i enjoy
greatly
like it so like when i'm on a team and
there's a girl that's very like
bossy and dominant but i respect as a
leader
that like i love like helping them out
with stuff
um
so
who would you guys say agree or disagree
then
um
i guess i guess i do avoid i would i'm
gonna put agree a little bit um you are
definitely not an artistic type of
person i'm a creative
um so i would say disagree
you would think the world would be a
better place if people rely more on
rationality and lessen their feelings
yeah i agree you prefer to do your
chores before allowing yourself to relax
i disagree but i'm trying to change that
um
okay
you enjoy watching people argue yeah i
love debates you tend to avoid drawing
attention to yourself no i'm on youtube
that's like the definition of drawing
attention to myself
but but i do hate wearing clothes
that are like super attention-grabbing
and i hate like
there's oh my gosh i
i hate
like i like being the center of a small
room but if there's like a ton of people
then i know too much
your mood can change very quickly i
agree
you lose patience with people who are
not as efficient as you
no not really
you often end up doing things the last
moment yeah
you've always been fascinated by the
question of what if anything happens
after death yes um
you usually prefer to be around others
rather than your own
than on your own
um
i do prefer to be around people but i
like to be around people with the same
interests as me so it depends on the
person but
um you become
bored or lose interest when the
discussion gets highly theoretical
disagree
um you find it easy to emphasize with a
person who experiences are very
different from yours i would say
agree
you usually postpone making final
decisions for as long as possible
i can think of times where i've been
early to a decision and late
i would say no i don't
but i'm going to just do a little bit
you rarely second
guess the choices you've made oh my gosh
oh wait no disagree i second-guess my
choices all the time
um after a long and exhausting week a
lively social event is just what you
need
yeah but the right type of social event
but
yeah you and you enjoy going to art
museums i know
you often have a hard time understanding
other people's
feelings my boyfriend always says i do
but i feel like
i feel like i
often have a hard time understanding
other people's feelings
i don't say disagree i don't think i
think i can understand
um you like to have a to-do list for
each day
um
i usually have a weekly to-do list so
i'm gonna say agree a little bit you
really feel insecure disagree i am like
the most insecure person i know um you
avoid making phone calls disagree
um you often spend a lot of time trying
to understand views that are different
from your own i would say agree
in your social circle
you are often the ones who contact your
friend and initiates activities agree
if your plans are interrupted your top
priority is to get on track as soon as
possible
agree you're still bothered by your
mistakes you made a long time ago um
let's say agree
you rarely contemplate the reasons for
human existence disagree your emotions
control you more than you control them
oh that's hard
i'd say disagree uh
i'm so logical but i'm emotional still
okay you take great care not to look at
peop to make people look bad even when
it is completely their fault no if it's
if i
disagree
your personal work style is closer to
spontaneous bursts of energy
yes when someone thinks highly of you
you wonder how long it will take for
them to feel disappointed in you
oh that'd be the core agree
um you would love a job that take that
requires you to work alone most of the
time
uh
well i want to do youtube but i feel
like youtube's different because you're
always talking to people so i'll say
disagree you believe that pondering
abstract facility
philosophy
oh my gosh philosophical questions is a
waste of time
i disagree you feel more drawn to places
with busy bustling atmospheres and quiet
intimate places
say agree a little bit you know at first
glance how someone is feeling
i disagree i would say i'm not the most
observant person you often feel
overwhelmed
no i think i should feel more
overwhelmed than i do
um you complete things method
meth
methodology without skipping over steps
oh god disagree you're very intrigued by
things labeled as controversial agree
um
you would pass along a good opportunity
if so you thought someone else needed it
more
well who's the someone like for a
stranger no
my close family
i would say no probably not
not just not just anyone um you struggle
with deadlines
i think i'm good with deadlines i'm just
not
i'll say i'll say agree a little bit you
feel confident that things will work out
for you
yeah actually i do okay you guys ready
drum roll please
i'm the baiter
the debater i think this is not what i
got last time actually
i feel like i got a new one i get like
three every single time
is that what you said
no you said you knew it you said are you
an intp earlier
cap
i you said i
not e
was it a typo
but i actually i'm pretty sure i got a
different one last time because i got
whatever one oprah was
yeah i i got
whatever because i remember being like
oh i'm like cool
obama and oprah
um got the same thing so i don't
remember what it was but it definitely
actually i bet i could look and tell you
if i read this i'll tell you all the
ones
that i've gotten because i've gotten
more than one
pipes
so i've gotten the debater that's what i
got this time
um
okay i've gotten the protagonist
entp you know what i bet you i know why
it switched because i used to think that
i like did want because i always used to
want to be in leadership positions
but i realized like recently that
naturally that's like not
oh and i got the campaigner i did get
the campaigner once
i think that's it though like i think
because i switched the leadership
i might have gotten the entertainer once
i've taken this so many times but i
always forget what i got but if i did it
was like once not a lot i know the three
that i've gotten the most was the
protagonist the campaigner
and the debater like those are the three
um
yeah i like i don't even know what these
really mean so
maybe it does like i don't i got no dog
in this fight